qui parmi vous elle était enfant ici je
vous parlais de trois choses que moi
reprise mais l'enfant sûr
l'innovation il ya quelque temps j'étais
installé tranquillement chez moi dans
mon salon et façon étonnante y avait
beaucoup d espace entre le canapé du
salon est là tabou ou en ville quelqu'un
avait déplacé
j'appelle les enfants c'était l'heure du
dîner
et quand ils ont descendu les escaliers
dans cet espace là ils sont milliard ils
sont bien avancés alors c'est les
enfants ils sont très très vif très
brillant aux s'y sont mis aussi à
chanter
un moment plein de vie plein de joie
c'était la première fois qu'il y avait
autant d' espaces dans le salon et
c'était la première fois qu'ils sont mis
à danser ici l'espace avec des remises
la création on comprend mieux la chose
hein vous vous êtes là installés dans
cet amphi avec des voisins à gauche et à
droite et pour tester des choses c'est
difficile art que moi je fais un peu ce
que je veux là sur scène en innovation
c'est la même chose
l'espace est clé si vous voulez trouver
des idées disruptive mieux va avoir une
bonne hauteur sous plafond
on appelle ça l'effet cathédrale
si au contraire vous voulez avec un
groupe où mettre d'accord sur une idée
mieux vaut les mettre dans une petite
pièce et 20 entreprises ont compris ça
une fois je travaillais pour une banque
je m'occupais de stratégie et on
cherchait de nouvelles idées pour
utiliser la blocs chaîne une technologie
qui utilisés pour les transactions
financières notamment pour le bitcoin
est ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on s'est
donné l'espace pour pour créer on s'est
donné un lieu et deux jours on a pu
rassembler une trentaine de personnes
des banquiers mais aussi des clients
pour dans cet espace là crée alors au
départ les banquiers avaient des idées
un peu bizarre il voulait utile à blocs
chaîne pour aller sur la lune
et puis un jour un moment un des clients
ali ben moi j'ai un problème avec vous
bon pied c'est que quand quand je fais
une transaction entre stuttgart et
singapour ça me prend douze jours douze
jours alors les gens se sont dit les
banquiers se sont dits dans cet espace
là d'où jour c'est énorme
et donc ils ont mis à tester et à
prototyper a essayé d'autres d'autres
solutions et et en deux jours on a
inventé un nouveau produit alors d'abord
on a fait la campagne de publicité et
puis le workflow et après pendant six
mois on a pu travailler dessus aussi
et à la fin créer un véritable produit
qui répondait à ce besoin là et à la fin
on est passé de 12 jours à un jour les
clients étaient contents les banquiers
étaient contents on dirait quand tu es
dans les journaux on se donne dans
l'espace on avait réussi à créer et
cette notion d' espace spatiale ça
marche aussi avec le temps vous prenez
par exemple google eux pour innover il
laisse les employés travailler sur leur
projet personnel jusqu'à 20% de leur
temps et avec ça ils ont créé gmail
service de messagerie utilisée par un
milliard de personnes sur la terre
plus d'un milliard vous rendez contre en
entrée vous laisser du temps libre à 20
% de vos employés et en sortie vous avez
la connaissance intime
partout les écrits et toutes les pensées
et tous les messages de 15% la
population mondiale
ça ça m'impressionne
et c'est vraiment ça ce que moi imprimés
en france sur l'innovation se donner
l'espace pour pouvoir créer pour pouvoir
innover
parce qu'il faut que je vous dise la
table dans le salon c'étaient eux qui
l'avaient déplacé
c'étaient eux qui s'était créé l'espace
pour pouvoir créer pour pouvoir innover
et vous quand vous travaillez sur vos
propres innovations
quel espace vous donner
chaque année c'est mardi gras et on m'a
dit guérin ma fille adore se déguiser
cette année elle s'est déguisée en art
déco et alors il faut que vous disant ma
fille adorable assez physique très
sportive tout ça là de bonnes notes à
l'école elle a plein de copains héééé
une fois par an elle se déguise en punk
ou assimilés c'est comme ça ça fait son
charme aussi ce qui est intéressant en
fait là dedans c'est la façon dont elle
prépare son déguisement plusieurs mois
avant mardi gras elle va tester
prototype et tout un ensemble de choses
par exemple elle va essayer un
maquillage et elle va aller voir son
frère et lui dit noam comment tu le
trouves au maquillage et lui fait il est
vraiment horrible
et là on sait que ça fonctionne une fois
aussi elle était là avec et elle était
en train de dessiner des faux ongles
jeudi mais c'est rennes
qu'est ce que tu fais elle me dit bah
papa j'essaye mais ongles et pourquoi
pas parce que même s'ils sont grandes il
ya de la foire que j'écrive bah ouais
c'est pas parce que vous déguiser de
façon un peu bizarre en harley quinn
avec des faux ongles à l'école qui va
pas falloir pouvoir continuer à
travailler et continuer à écrire
et c'est bien cette chose-là importante
que moi appris de mes enfants sur
innovation osé tester et prototypes et
de façon simple ses idées dans les
entreprises c'est la même chose
en fait c'est même souvent plus
difficile une fois j'étais je donnais
une formation sur tout ce qui à
l'innovation et on invitait les gens à
attester prototype est là sur des cartes
de visite
donc en dix minutes ils avaient créé des
cartes de visite et puis après il est
testé avec entre un moment j'ai demandé
à quelqu'un
c'était comment de faire cet exercice là
et le gars me dit ah c'était
stressant mais je dis mais pourquoi pas
c'était super stressant de pouvoir
présenter des choses un client alors que
ce n'était pas fini
alors j'ai demandé à la personne qui
jouait les clients et pour toi c'était
comment de donner ton avis sur un
prototype pas fini en tant que client et
lui il m'a dit ah bah c'était super j'ai
pu donner mon avis est comme ça à
l'étape suivante le second prototype
était beaucoup mieux
et ouais intéressant sept différentes
perceptions des choses de la même façon
une fois avec un client on voulait
tester des nouveaux services digitaux
c'était pour des agriculteurs donc on va
voir les agriculteurs on avait fait des
prototypes qui était un peu assez moche
c'était du powerpoint et tout le monde
vous avez dire bon les agriculteurs pour
ces services là ils ont besoin de de
mettre ça sur des stops sur ordinateur
fixe donc on fait le test avec les
agriculteurs
et sur les quatre agriculteurs les
quêtes me disent mais nous on ne peut
pas travailler sur des stops on doit
forcément avoir une version sur des
mobiles dans l'ordre du mérite pourquoi
ça ben tout simplement parce que nous à
partir de 7 heures du matin on est dans
les champs et ouais y'a pas de prix là
on a pu aussi lors de cette phase de
test découvrir plein de choses simples
sûr c'était quoi les besoins latents de
ces personnes là bref tester les
prototypes et peut être souvent très
utile
être à l'écouté de l'autre et c'est bien
cette seconde chose que moi a prises
mes enfants osé tester et prototypes et
des choses pas forcément finie mais pour
apprendre et pour s'améliorer
et vous quand vous réfléchissez à une
start-up auprès de personnes pour
l'attester concept sur un projet
innovant
combien de fois où est ce que vous le
prototype est souvent le week end
j'aime bien aller travailler sur des
projets un peu innovant et pour ça je
vais dans un fab lab sable ça veut dire
fabrication de laboratory bon si juste
un atelier ans est rimbaud un peu classe
pour dire atelier mai
c'est un endroit où on peut travailler
le bois le métal ce genre de choses et
quand j'y vais mon fils ma compagne est
souvent lui aussi il aime bien
travailler sur ses propres projets et
ses propres projets innovants pour lui
ce sont souvent des armes des doigts
américain des petits pics comme ça alors
comme j'ai testé cette histoire un
certain nombre de fois je peux vous dire
qu'après 25 % des personnes qui sont un
peu choqué par cette histoire là je peux
vous dire que moi aussi au début ça m'a
un peu étonné je me suis dit ok c'est
mon fils il est plutôt sage à l'école
ils jouent au foot avec tout le monde
il a plein de copains hyper sociable et
hey hey hey hey
il compte y travaillent sur des projets
innovants c'est des armes non pas qu'ils
les utilisent
mais c'est juste que ok ça la muse puis
aussi je me dis ok mais dans un pays en
france où à l'armement ses 12 5% du pipe
je me dis aussi que les armes ça peut
être utile peut-être pour tuer des
projets moi je travaille sur des projets
plus classique là c'est une rose en
métal mais plus peaceful mais je le
finis pas toujours et c'est bien ça qui
est intéressant en fait quand je regarde
mon fils voire faire les choses c'est sa
capacité de persévérance il peut passer
des heures à regarder des tuto sur
youtube pour voir comment travailler le
métal ou différentes étapes
après il faut passer des heures aussi à
table du salon pour améliorer ses
projets et c'est bien la troisième chose
que m'ont appris mes enfants sur
l'innovation c'est cette capacité de
persévérance et vous avez plein
d'innovateur qui ont fait cette chose là
par exemple
edison pour arriver à faire fonctionner
ces ampoules il a testé jusqu'à 1000
composition différente pour arriver à
trouver la bonne lan poule qui allait
durer ou plus près de nous elon musk
lui son rêve c'était de faire décoller
et se poser une fusée et il a eu un
nombre d'échecs mais hallucinant d'abord
ils essaient d'acheter des fusées russes
il s'est fait blackboulé deux fois april
a essayé de faire décoller des fusées
les trois premiers un échec total
explosion une fois qu'il a réussi à les
faire décoller il a essayé de les faire
poser la même chose trois échecs totaux
mais en 2014
il atteint son grand rêve faire décoller
une fusée et faire en sorte qu'elles se
posent il a recréé le congrès de tintin
on a marché sur la lune
la persévérance
la troisième chose que m'ont appris de
mes enfants sur l'innovation
alors j'ai regardé la définition du mot
innovation dans le petit larousse
je m'appelle labrousse un innovation
processus qui va de la naissance d'une
idée à sa matérialisation et là dessus
nous enfants mois a appris qu'il était
important de se donner l'espace osé
tester les prototypes et et persévérer
que des choses relativement simple 1
avec assez peu de théorie c'est plus une
logique de mise en action de mouvement
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
cette capacité des enfants à innover a
été prouvé scientifiquement
c'est ce qu'on appelle le marshmallow
challenge ça fonctionne comment des
équipes de 4 18 minutes un peu de
matériel avec des marshmallows des
spaghettis de la ficelle du scotch et un
challenge ça la tour la plus haute
possible et en général ça donne des
choses plutôt sympathiques comme ça on a
le marshmallow
ce qui est intéressant par rapport à ça
c'est que on a fait des statistiques là
dessus et on s'est aperçu que les
équipes d'enfants de moins de cinq ans
sont plus performantes que les équipes
de chefs d'entreprise d'accord et on
s'est aussi aperçu que bon les équipes
d'ingénieurs d'architectes était quand
même légèrement au dessus tout va bien
pour eux j'ai l'impression qu'on a
quelques uns ici
alors j'espère qu'il ya pas trop
d'étudiants en école de commerce ou ou
d'avocats parce que c'est catastrophique
mais je tiens à les rassurer la dernière
fois que j'ai fait l'exercice moi aussi
c'était assez catastrophique avec mon
équipe on n'a pas réussi à faire tenir
le le marshmallow en est selon ton
s'aperçoit quand on les regarde
fonctionné c'est que les enfants ils
vont pas passer dix sept minutes à dire
qui va faire les plans qui va être le
chef qui va être le sous-chef ils sont
plus sur le mode de jeu mais le
marshmallow en eau et je teste
différentes choses et jt agité un jt
agité agitèrent en fait c'est un peu ce
que j'ai expliqué il se donne l'espace
les 18 minutes
il teste les prototypes en mettant le
marshmallow en eau et à la fin ils
persévèrent là dessus ce qu'on a vu
c'est que vous avez tous la capacité de
d'innover et d'inventer le monde de
demain
vous êtes tous cette capacité d'innover
de se trouver l'espace 2 et tester les
prototypes et et d'oser persévérer alors
allez-y osé
[Applaudissements]